the mystery was how tall is jake
gyllenhaal and you said there's jake
gyllenhaal right there and you say I you
wanted to figure out how tall he was
because someone said that they were I
guess going on Google and finding
different heights for him you went to
great lengths to figure out how tall
Jake Gyllenhaal is is that right I did
because so there's a whole website
called celeb heights calm and there's
people who argue about how tall
celebrities are celebrities they've
never met and this one there was like
pages and pages and pages of people
fighting about how tall Jake Gyllenhaal
was well it's so funny like why I mean I
love Jake Gyllenhaal but it's like why
are they zero in on this one guy and say
like how tall exactly is is he it's just
crazy
they just well they were consumed by cuz
it wasn't even they didn't even care
they don't even thing he's short they
were saying they were arguing over
whether he was 510 or 5 10 and 3/4 like
they weren't trying to take him down
they just were really obsessed with like
actually knowing the actual number and
so I took on the case and he entered the
case I'm on this case I Calle
[Applause]
yeah actually I ended up exe came on the
show and he told me how tall he was
right and he and do you want me tell you
Italians yeah so he said he said is what
he said he said he was five eleven and a
half five eleven and a half okay so you
announced that but it didn't end the
mystery it didn't end the mystery so
then the celeb Heights changed the entry
they had him at six feet before they
changed it to five eleven and a half
they said Jake himself said it and then
within like a day or two some comander
came on and was laying I don't know this
source does not seem very reliable Jay
it's Jaejoong they did not the hell is
there a problem
I think it's cuz they heard it they
heard it and didn't this is the world we
live in the Internet of like you have
him actually saying how tall I am which
is you know and then no no one believes
it they would not buy and then other
people started to pipe into and be like
yeah you're right this is this nemesis
really suspicious yes and I think it's
gonna didn't see it yeah well let's
crack this once and for all Jake do you
mind
[Applause]
thank you
I didn't quite get him hold on let's get
this done right now let's not waste any
time and I am getting well I gotta say
I'm getting closer to 6 feet than I am
yeah I'm gonna say I'm gonna say you are
here that here is okay I'm gonna say
yeah I know why 511 I'm getting 511
right here what yeah what are you
getting you tell me I'm getting 511 I
can't even see that high up for you you
know what there's you know there's a
thing called max morning height this is
what you learned on I learned on fly
height where you start off at your he
started off the height is tight in the
morning and then as you go through the
day and the world beats you down right
have you had a rough day today been uh
it's been ma it's been about a half of
an inch
[Laughter]
Thank You Jake
I'll give you that this is doesn't
measure this doesn't measure